hey there and welcome to conan o'brien
needs a friend voted uh i believe
podcast of the century by time and
newsweek no i didn't hear that i just
made it up oh the fact that you said
newsweek too yeah
is there still a news i don't think so
what are you going on a computer to find
out no i'm going to order an edition of
newsweek
i think it's online but i don't think
the print edition exists all i'm saying
is you're right i don't think anyone's
going to look into it so i'm going to
start making outlandish claims about the
success of our podcast
you know we are a successful podcast but
i'm just going to start throwing out
right after the introduction
and welcome to conan o'brien needs a
friend
um just voted
best hour of entertainment by good
housekeeping magazine oh best hour of
entertainment yeah and that that's all
time meaning it stacks up against any
movie it stacks up against any book that
takes uh you could read for an hour
anything that would take an hour of your
time hey it was good housekeeping it
wasn't me okay l magazine said that we
are the most fashion-forward podcast no
that's true i think yeah
i wear incredible outfits i don't think
people realize just for the podcast and
don't bother trying to look up online at
the video
yeah there's a video component to this
you're wearing a dark polo shirt uh no
he's wearing eddie murphy's red suit
from raw yeah the leather zip suit i
bought that and it's i didn't realize
that it's uh it's made
it's made of pressed and dried beet
it's a veg it's an entirely vegetable
made suit
i did wear on tour we did a takeoff of
that we wore a copy of the other suit
that eddie murphy wore
it was kind of a purple yellow one yeah
and i got measured for it and i wore
that this is whatever 11 years ago or
something and i wore it on tour and i
lost so much weight on the tour because
i would burn like 9 000 calories a night
doing this show and we would do a show a
night and travel all around the country
and
at the end of the tour the thing is
falling off yeah you were sickly
but i mean i had it you know it and and
so it just looks
i look like a prisoner in like a
confederate soldier's camp
who had who put on an eddie murphy raw
suit and tried to do stand-up it was the
most
i know yeah the most ridiculous uh i
wonder where that suit is it must exist
somewhere you know we have a crazy this
occurs to me i have saved everything
from the very beginning you know from
from my time with saturday night live
simpsons i found
legal pad page where i kind of came up
with the idea for the monorail oh my god
you're kidding me no and i have it
and um i put it in my drawer because i
just thought like oh this is cool but
you can see me come up with it and then
sketch out monorail question mark and
then i sketch out a couple things but in
addition to that any kooky prop that i
particularly liked and think of the
billions of them yeah um we would i
would always say oh just put it in
storage just put it in storage so you
know at the end of the famous movie
citizen kane
they're going through citizen kane has
uh has died charles foster kane has died
and they're going through his massive
estate and they're just throwing
everything in the fire
and and that's where you see them throw
the sled in but they're slow they're
throwing in paintings and all this stuff
that he collected in his life my ending
my citizen kane ending is going to be
the funniest thing in the world
because it's going to be literally like
a toilet seat that somebody made into a
guitar
and sent to me and uh i i was like wow
this is so weird but i gotta keep it put
it in storage you know what i mean yeah
or we once had a we had a stuffed
squirrel with a backpack that used to go
in circles i think i have that some on
the show i have it's just gonna be
workmen and conan o'brien passed away
and his many gourds were thrown into the
fireplace
above his palatial palace and you're
just gonna see
is that what's gonna happen masturbating
bear diaper oh no what is your rosebud
though what's that one thing oh my god
that's a really good question what is
the rose but what is the thing i'm gonna
be saying yeah like as i leave this
earth from from your youth probably is
it that no it's gonna be something from
my own costume that you're remember we
brought bought one that was like my mom
my mom
tried to do a sweet thing and she bought
a
costume for me for halloween
and it was and it was at the height of
like watergate yeah and people hating
america
and she bought me
she wanted me to dress like uncle sam
yeah and i mean vietnam protests were
still going on
and watergate and it was an it was a
plastic uncle sam face and then uncle
sam and um
i was i was not happy and i let my mom
know it and i think i heard her feelings
which to this day hurts my fee i mean
bothers me yeah of course but um but
yeah i'll i'll be like uncle sam
uncle sam and then you'll see that mask
being thrown on the fire yeah i know if
it's going to be that or something from
the comedy
[Music]
career you know like a fake mustache i
wore in the old time baseball remote
or um or you find out there actually was
little threads connected to your pockets
when you did that dance i did that dance
at the top of the show
yeah the only thing anybody knows about
me all around the world i swear to god
you could drop me down in a rural
province in china and they would point
at me and then do the string dance thing
yeah where i act like there were strings
attached to my hips it transcends
languages and cultures and common sense
yeah it transcends all intelligence yeah
it does uh
i don't think they'll burn your stuff i
would sell it and keep all no one's
gonna buy any of that [ __ ] no one's
gonna buy any of it people buy anything
they'll buy it to burn it
conan's burning his stuff i want to burn
his stuff
[Music]
yeah yeah i'm uh
yeah we should do that i do want to make
sure sona you're you're at a seat of
things what are the two things here to
see do first is the burning of all my
stuff okay and and you have to make sure
that it's filmed in beautiful black and
white
uh in a giant warehouse okay and all the
weird crap that i've gotten over the
years the second thing
is what have i i've always asked you
please make sure they don't don't bury
you at the forest lawn cemetery yeah i
think yeah i don't want to be buried at
forest lawn cemetery is that a danger
that that could happen because no one
ever thinks ahead and i'm noticing that
everyone gets married married there
everyone why did i confuse marriage with
dad oh dear oh oh my god you want to
take that again no yeah maybe my wife
should listen to this episode you know
as a joke i'm going to not burn your
stuff and bury you at forest line
i want to be some place leafy you know i
know and uh and the fact that you're
just on a hill and overlooking the 134
freeway overlooking the 134 freeway yeah
people are on their way to go see
michael jackson and they step on my
grave
i don't want that it'll be so funny no
yes no in the future everyone i don't
even need to be buried as i've told you
just leave me naked in a field somewhere
oh so that people can find i want a
jogger to find me like on every episode
of law and order i want a jogger to go
like what the hey look at that hey
someone dropped an alabaster statue of a
woman
oh my god it's the body of conan o'brien
they're naked and they still mistake you
for a woman they still think i'm a woman
coyotes have eaten part of you nope no
he's not untouched yeah that's right
that's that's what the court they don't
want to eat him no no no
no then the excuse that p that my
publicist tries to make as well why do
they think he was a woman well coyotes
got to his genitals and then
and then and then the coroner speaks up
and goes actually no that's the one part
that coyotes didn't get
generals were intact
he still looks an awful lot like a woman
if anything why would the coroner have
to puff up at that point they're a
little swollen just from decay gases if
anything in the sun they grew to twice
in this in the sun they grew to twice
their size but still looks a lot like
female genitalia and people were like
would you shut the [ __ ] up
anyway he'll be laid to rest at for as
long
followed by the preservation not burning
of all of his useless crap